Hello there and welcome to today's episode of
Rawkode live. I'm your host,
Rawkode.
Now I wanna take a moment before we
get started to just thank my employer providing
the time
for me to put a show together and
produce learning materials for us all to learn
together.
If you want to try Equinix Medal, which
is a bare metal cloud platform, then you
can use the code Rawkode live. This will
give you $50 in credit.
That credit can be splurged over a few
hours over n two x large x 86
machines with a whopping 400 gig of ram
almost.
If you wish to be a little bit
more conservative, then you can start at 50¢
an hour and you're still getting a fairly
chunky machine.
If you're not watching this live and you
wanna have conversations or ask questions, feel free
to join our discord community at Rawkode live
slash chat
And please remember to hit that subscribe button
so that more people will find this content.
Thanks.
Today, we're gonna take a look at Dgraph
and I am at the pleasure of being
joined by Dgraph's
community engineer,
Swanee Chew.
Hello.
How are you? Good. Good. Good. Yourself?
Yeah. Very well. Thank you. Good. I appreciate
that it is a little bit late. This
is the biggest time zone difference I've had
to deal with so far in this show.
Eleven hours, I believe. It is what? 9PM
for you at the moment? It is. It
is. And,
know, thank you for for being so flexible.
No. No. No. Thank you. I'm really looking
forward to today's episode. You know, Dgraph I
think is a really cool tool. I've used
it very superficially and I'm hoping that you're
gonna correct all of those bad habits that
I potentially picked up as I've been experimenting.
So before we get started, do wanna just
take a moment to maybe you know, introduce
yourself, talk about what you do, and then
we'll lead into what Dgraph is and what
problem it's trying to solve.
Yeah. So I'm Shanid.
You very you you got my name quite
well. Thank you.
I'm the community engineer at Dgraph, and what
I do is I wrangle the community. I
basically
I I'm the ear of the queue. I
I listen to what the community says. I
I provide feedback from the community back into
the engineers.
I also do outreach kind re related kind
of works, which is why I'm here.
Yeah. So previously, I was I was doing
machine learning research,
being a data scientist for more than fifteen
ish years.
And Dgraph is really interesting to me because
it's it it comes from,
knowledge knowledge graphs.
You know those little boxes that you see
on Google?
Uh-huh.
Yeah. Those those boxes were, like, created by
the guy who founded Dgraph, Manish.
Alright.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So so so pretty much
the same things that powered those little one
boxes
is what powers Dgraph.
Okay. So to to
confirm that, like, when I search for
Donald Trump, there's that little box on the
right that says, this is all the information
we have on this person and here are
the links to the other sites. That but
that is powered by a graph database and
by the person who started to do It's
powered by a knowledge graph, which Knowledge graph.
You can build using Dgraph.
The the underlying technologies would be quite the
same as Dgraph. In fact, if if you
look at Dgraph source code, you'll find a
lot of terms that are related to search
engines. Right? You got words like posting lists,
keywords like posting lists, and and these are
ideas that came from from manage building a
a search engine,
essentially.
Okay. So why don't we kind of
kind of dive into that a little bit
then? So when people are building
their their applications, right, it's very easy and
for people to reach to a database where
they've got experience of using before. You know,
I can think
firsthand of many things where I or my
team would pick MariaDB or would pick Postgres
just because those are tools we've used before.
So what is
what is the decision process then when people
are saying, okay, maybe I should start to
look at using a graph database like Dgraph.
Like, what what is there a certain type
of data? Is there a certain type of
problem that this really fits naturally to that
people should make that leap out of their
comfort zone?
Right. So
Rawkode has a has a very famous saying,
something along the lines of if you structure
your data right, the algorithms follow.
Right? So if if you think about the
data
of the domain of the problem that you're
trying to solve,
right, if you're trying to build a Twitter
clone, for example,
would you be would your data really be
in form of tables,
or would your table be graph like?
Right? So your users will be following each
other. You'll be posting tweets and stuff like
that, for example.
Now think about the the structure of the
data in your head. Right? Are they tables?
Naturally,
as as they are. Right? Naturally,
as they are. Are they tables or are
they graphs?
So so if you have a if you
have a dataset if if you've got a
bunch of data at the at your data
structure,
if if they're table format, like,
you know, they they are don't get me
wrong. There are absolutely
a lot of data where where tables are
the best way to handle it.
But a lot of data is best handled
by something like a graph or a tree.
In fact, graphs and trees are so ubiquitous.
They're they're they're considered fundamentals
in computer science. We we we Yeah. Talk
about graphs and trees all the time in
computer science and not anywhere else. Right? So,
it's a very good way if you to
to to to to figure out whether you
should use graph databases to have to think
about what
your data structure actually look like. Right?
Yeah. What's the structure of your data in
its in its natural form?
Okay. Alright. So I guess
when when people are making these sorts of
decisions, mean, they should really start to understand
what data model they're trying to accomplish, what
kind of query workloads they're gonna have. They
wanna understand that they need to, you know,
as I get something that we all see
time and time again, is we throw stuff
into these traditional relational databases and we add
all of these indices and all of these
complex joins and then we have Yeah. We
complain
about the mess when we try to build
a SQL query to create that back out
and the problem is we're just probably not
using the right data structures. We're not using
the right database technology
Exactly. That's where Dgraph can hopefully, you know,
the examples and the way that we're gonna
play with it today will hopefully get people
a more visual. Oh, like I get it
now and this is why I should start
using this technology and I think search like
you said is a fantastic thing. Search is
a graph that we wanna be able to
fill that down and present it in a
way that is relevant to people. And I
think Yeah. Fine. Based on my naive understanding
so far, this is where this database technology
really shines.
Did it that's correct.
Search is search is one of the things
well, searching a knowledge graph. Right? So searching
is often it's it's often when when it
comes to search, it's often easier to search
through tables because you take a table a
table is essentially a list, and you split
the list into half. You search the top
half. You search the bottom half anywhere that
you find it. You just focus your area,
you know, in in a binary search.
Yep.
Yeah.
So
search is often for for a lot of
dataset, search is search fits with tables. But
for the kinds of dataset that most web
applications use, like the big,
apps nowadays, well, they they they
if you ask me to draw, I would
draw a graph or a tree. You know,
and that's where a graph database fits in.
Alright. Why don't we
get this installed and then show people what
we're working with and then we'll start to
model out some of this data. And again,
I think just the process of walking through
this is gonna provide
that they understand and that people need to
get started here. So I will,
through the power of the internet, share my
screen. So this is the dgraph.io
homepage.
Yep.
So
I do also have the documentation
and slash graph q l. Now I'm not
sure what that is, but I'm sure we're
gonna get to it shortly.
Do you wanna explain
right now or do you want do you
want me to? Yeah. We'll bring it in
naturally. Whenever you feel that we we wanna
move towards whatever that is, then we'll just
we'll have to talk about it And
just as a reminder to the people watching
that there is very little done upfront. And
the only thing that we have done upfront
is
pull the Dgraph Docker image. So that's Dgraph
slash Dgraph
and pull down the latest version. And I
can see that in our shared buffer, you've
very kindly provided me a very quick Docker
run command just to get this started. Is
that the first
step? Is that what is well, hold on.
Let me pull up the So so
the the docs to install Docker is actually
in the front page.
If you go to to deploy
sorry. Click deploy. Yep. Yep. Yeah.
And download. Right? You've got download on the
left sidebar.
There we go. Okay. Cool.
Yeah. So
is that step on then? We're just gonna
run this image. I can see that it's
exposing a bunch of ports so we can
talk about what is going on there. Yes.
Do want me to walk you through what's
happening? Okay. So
when you install Postgres, what do you expect?
You when when you install Postgres, it's just
one application that you run. Right?
But Dgraph is is out of the box,
Dgraph is built to be, like,
distributed
so that one application
will have to do several roles.
So Dgraph itself is split into two things.
It's called zero and alpha.
Dgraph zero is the coordinator,
so it coordinates the cluster,
and
alpha is where the data sits.
Okay. So this standalone image has got all
the the the configurations
for,
the alpha and zeros.
What happens is when when you when you
have things that are distributed out of the
box, you've got to put a bit more
thought into into how you're gonna deploy your
application. Right?
So on
a on a
the standalone doc image basically gives you all
that in in a standalone for you to
play with.
But when you deploy it, you need to
actually
give a lot more thought.
Okay. So by default, Dgraph is a horizontally
scalable
graph database.
Yep. That's right. Okay. Nice. I just need
to tweak this a little bit.
Yeah. I'm just gonna use a named volume
so that I don't have to meant anything
locally.
Yeah. We're exposing port sixty eighty eighty eighty
So sixty eighty would be the zero.
That's the zero. 60 80.
80 80 and ninety eighty are the alphas,
and 8,000 is the clients.
There's something there there is something called Rattle,
which is the Dgraph clients. I'll
show you how it looks like afterwards
when when you get this running. Yeah. Let's
get it started.
Oh,
it's the standalone image. Right. Okay. Cool. It
was quick anyway. So we're good.
So load the logs. It looks like it's
starting up. I'm assuming it's just trying to
do a leader election of its own. Yep.
And it seems And there you go. It
should be done. So if you go to
your browser,
go to local host 8,000.
Welcome to Rattle. This is the interface of
Dgraph.
Choose latest.
Yep.
So this is this is your interface to
this is basically like a
what's it called? P g p g admin.
The PHP version of admin or or
Yeah. Okay. What's it called? Seek SQL my
admin.
Oh, yeah. I don't Yeah.
PHP my admin. That's the tool. This is
just like a UI for the administration,
and it's even got some query stuff built
in for Dgraph. Oh, and and and it's
got pretty some some pretty cool stuff. But
you've essentially got Dgraph.
You've got a database running just like that.
Right?
So
so I need to explain to you a
bit, a bit more about about Dgraph right
now. So Dgraph as a database supports two
languages.
Right? So this is DQL,
also known as Dgraph query language
and GraphQL.
Okay. So GraphQL, I'm quite familiar with. So
that should I'm assuming
that's gonna feel oh, hopefully feel quite natural
to me. But DQL,
I'm not familiar with. So can we talk
DQL looks like GraphQL. In fact, it was
it it it was sort it sort sort
of started off as a fork of GraphQL.
There were things there are still things that
GraphQL cannot do.
So you keep extending it, extending it, extending
it, and and and suddenly it goes, oh,
right.
You know?
It looks a bit different from,
GraphQL now.
Alright. So we've got no data.
So like like in GraphQL,
you you can you can write a query
just like that. Look at your Versus code.
So so in in in
what what do you call it? Let's see.
In in GraphQL,
you you you say what you want. Right?
Mhmm. So you name a function
like that,
And then,
for example, okay.
And then you tell me the fields that
you want.
So this is this is how DQL looks
like.
Yep. It looks a bit like GraphQL, doesn't
it?
It's yeah. It's very, familiar for sure. Definitely.
So the only difference are these. Right?
Yeah. Some sort of, like, named parameter. Is
that what's going on here? You pass it
in and then there's a function or something.
Right? I I don't know. I'll let you
tell me. Okay. A funk is basically what's
needed at the at the root note of
the graph.
Okay.
So you say, I I wanna look at
all the nodes,
in a graph
that has a type.
This is what it says.
Okay.
Now what is a node and what's a
what what what's a what's a node in
a graph? Well, this is where a graph
database comes in. In a graph database, you
store your your data in nodes.
And and a node is is is an
abstract thing. Right? It's not like a piece
of something.
The node in Dgraph is, it's a 64
bit
integer,
unsigned integer. Right?
And and to give
now imagine you've you've got a sea of
little numbers everywhere.
Right?
They're not useful. You need to give it
some structure.
So
the fundamentals
of Dgraph is type system,
and,
let's get to it. If you could could
could pull up Rattle again.
Yes.
So if you query something like that, if
you if you write a a similar query,
you're not gonna get anything. Right? You've got
no data. Yeah.
So you go to click, click on schema,
and and this is where it gets a
bit interesting because,
Dgraph Dgraph does not follow the GraphQL schema.
Right? K.
Oh, sorry. Charles crying. Right.
So
let's talk about schemas then.
What what what data do you wanna write?
What what do you want to
So can we, like
let's just make up something really trivial. I
I I'd like to just get write some
data, clean the data, see how that workflow
works. So what what's the simplest can we
just have a schema where we we just
store my name? Like Actually, go go to
console. You I I'll show you this even.
You don't need, like, a strict schema. Just
click mutate. Oh, okay.
Open opens curly brace.
Set,
curly brace
Curly brace. And then underscore
colon
node one,
n o d e one, yes, space. Oh.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It can be any name.
You just put a variable there. Right? So
that's an variable space. Angle bracket,
name,
close bracket.
Put put your name there.
I got it. Space space before Yeah. Yeah.
Space. Yep. Okay. David and space,
full stop.
Yep.
And then the next line
Underscore
colon node one.
Give yourself give her a property that you're
interested in.
Right. You know?
Full stop.
And run this.
Okay.
Go.
Oh,
What did I break?
Alright.
Sorry. You need to put put your
age in in cut
quotes.
Oh, okay.
So let's try and understand that. So there's
a braces I understand. Right? This is a
breaking into
a JSON style object for GraphQL. We're using
some sort of set mutation function.
Yep. I'm not sure. The underscore just mean
I I don't know what the underscore means,
but I'm assuming from other programming languages adopt
an underscore. It just means I don't care
about an ID. I don't Yeah. You're absolutely
correct.
You you don't have an ID.
Okay. And then that's one.
Yeah. You call it node one within this
context of this query. Right? You call it
node one, and you say we'll set a
new relationship called David a name. Sorry.
And the value of that that that relationship
is called David. Full stop.
Right. Okay. And this is
this is tied to my age based on
that node one as a common identifier?
Correct.
Okay. So what does that look like? Can
we query this now?
Yeah. Sure.
It could
just write the same thing that I give
it a name. Give it a name. No.
Just do no. No. Listen.
Give give it a name. Give your function
a name.
My funk or something. Okay. I just like
to call it, yeah, fetch. And then inside
the
braces, just write funk.
Oh, yep.
Parenthes and parents func space
colon. Sorry.
E q,
open,
paren,
and let's see. E q name
and then David.
Like that? EQ name comma David.
Name comma
David.
Alright. Okay. So EQ is a function. We're
passing in the name as alright. Okay. Got
it. Yep.
And then you need to bring back some
data. So UID.
Okay.
No no no comma.
Name age.
Name.
So.
Alright. Run it. You see some very interesting
things on the right.
I
forgot.
Ah, okay.
Right. So instead
if I okay. So I think I understand
the error rate. It's saying that we haven't
we haven't told it to index on any
of those properties. It's not. Yeah. Exactly. Can
we just remove the the equals and pull
back all data? I believe that will not
I believe that will not run, but you
can try it.
Yeah. Yeah. So you you need something. So
has,
just func has type has
yeah.
Has,
open brace
type TIP.
Yeah. Nothing's showing up because there's no type.
Right? Okay.
So you say you've not actually created a
type.
Alright. So you you can type func has
instead of has type, you just type,
let's see, any of terms,
I guess.
Oh, no. No. You cannot. You still need
you need you still need an index. So
just go back to your schema. Yeah. Okay.
Now you see
age and type. Right? So you need to
yep. Okay. You figured it out. So click
index,
update.
It's very easy.
Oh, type here. You should type this string.
Yeah. I just keep clicking things and then
see what happens. So, you know, just tell
me when I do something. Okay.
So you you want exact
or hash?
Yeah. But exact only basically allows you to
match on on on EQ.
Yeah. What we what we did there is
we're modifying the schema. We set the type
of name to be a string and then
in order to index it, it has to
know how to index it for the lookup
that I want.
Kind of familiar with these terms a little
bit. So exact, I'm assuming means if I
do David, I could find it but I
wouldn't be able to do a wild card
match on
DAV or anything like that. Correct. Okay. Cool.
Well, I mean, I'm just gonna keep clicking
on stuff. I'm gonna see that my age
be an integer.
I'll just index that too and then click
update.
So
let's see.
Does that mean that I can go back
to your EQ function?
Yeah. And the the David. Okay. If you
if you scroll down, you can see the
history as well. So Oh, yeah. Cool. Nice.
Tada. There you go.
Alright. I was paying attention. Okay. So Now
click on the click on the little thing
that says showing one note and zero edges.
Yeah. Yeah. Click on that. No. No. The
little box.
The the box.
Click on David.
There we go. There you go.
So
like I said, all all all nodes are
basically
an unsigned int, and we call that a
u UID.
Right? And this UID has this node has
pro related properties of age and name.
Let's just add some more data into this.
Okay. Just put my name, g x y,
and put put a thousand for my age
or something. Right?
If you run this
you see, it's still called node one.
Yeah? Yep. But if you go to query
and you run this Oh. Sorry.
So has
name.
So it changes to has name.
Yep.
Ah.
Nice. So so did you see the pop
up that says has name and then, yes,
like, angle angle brackets
in in the suggestion? Yeah. I did. So
when I did this, we had these yeah.
I did notice that. So so the the
bottom one's the canonical form.
That's the prefer that's the the good form
that nobody actually uses.
As far as I've seen people type code,
people don't actually do that.
But I personally do that. So
Okay. So is there, like,
are there any advantages
to using the canonical form? Like, does a
No. You you won't you won't run into,
like,
what's it called, escaping issues.
Ah, right. Okay. Gotcha.
So I see that we've got back two
nodes and I like that I can drag
things about which is Yeah. You can see
things. Superficial, but it's cool.
But I noticed we don't have a relationship.
It's Yep.
Could say that one? Yeah. We can.
So let's go back to mutate.
Okay.
Now
this is this is where we need to
think about it. Right?
So instead of underscore, you need to know
you can click on the image.
You can click on your ID or my
ID. Mhmm.
So you can see u x UIDs OX
1,
and then my my ID would be UIDOX
2. Uh-huh. Okay.
So fill in the first underscore
with
u OX 1.
Alright. Okay. Cool. And then change the name
of the relationship.
The o x one needs to be in
in in Oh, yeah. Denise in in angle
brackets. Oh, angle brackets. Sorry. Angle brackets. Oh,
the canonical form. Yep.
And,
you don't need the colon thing already because
you know the ID. Right? So Ah, yeah.
Okay. Okay. So you only need one one.
Right? And,
say,
live streams.
And then instead of q x y, just
put o x two.
Yeah. Run it. That was quite intuitive. I
I like
Okay. Now go back to the query.
I run this query again. Oh, we have
to that has to pull out livestreams?
Yep.
Yeah. You figured this out.
Well, that's interesting.
Ah, right. Sorry. Sorry.
Instead of has name, just put has livestream.
See? It's only one. So if you go
to livestreams
and open a curly brace there
Mhmm.
And put
UID name and age.
I knew you were gonna see that.
Oh, there you go. Would I use the
canonical form here too?
No? If you want.
I just I said it was an option.
So I Yeah. Yeah. I don't I don't
use the canonical form in queries. But Ah,
okay.
Okay.
I won't do that then. Alright. And then
we have a lane.
Yeah.
And it's telling me, yep, we have
a a livestream.
Cool.
Now we should learn how to constrain the
data.
Okay?
Can you what do you what do you
mean by constrain the data then?
Well, put more structure.
Introduce a notion of types, I guess.
Ah, right. Okay. Gotcha. Okay. Alright. So
so so this is the best part. Right?
Go back to
go back to mutate.
Okay. Now if you go o x one,
change livestream to reads,
and then put a book name,
any book that you in in strings.
Okay. Just click run.
So now you can see that there's two
separate sets of data. Two two two separate
concepts. One's a livestream edge. One's the livestream
of type edge.
One's an edge of type livestream and the
other's an edge of
I see you've got good taste in science
fiction. Very good. Very good.
Yeah. I just had a I was I
wanted to add too so that we could
see because I I really like this view
of the data, the very visual view of
the data. And I thought we'd add two
so we we have a little bit more
going on there. So
and I do love tuning the body problems.
So So if you click reads,
you create a new so so you what
you can do is you can create a
new field, call call it reads.
So you want me back on mute it?
No. No. No. In in in the query
stream. Right? So so
k. So we're doing reads.
Yeah.
And then UID. Yep.
Run it.
But we still have this predicate here. Right?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So I just changed
that predicate to to has type again. Oh,
has type. Okay.
I think has type will not work. Sorry.
Yeah. Has you've not introduced type, so
equals David.
Okay. So name
David.
There we go.
You click on David.
See?
There's only one reads.
Yeah.
I
thought
why?
Types. We need types. Right. Okay. Anyway, so
so if you go underscore
go to UID under reads under reads and
change that to underscore
underscore underscore
expand all
x underscore underscore expand bracket all.
Oh, wait.
Pardon me? Pepper and oh, yeah. Yep.
Yep. Run this. It should I think that's
the way the
one second. That's okay. Expand predicates.
Sorry. It's expand
underscore all.
I keep forget I keep forgetting where so
it's expand the the the the the function
is called expand
Oh.
Without an underscore? Yeah. Underscore
underscore underscore.
Okay. Expand and then open parens and then
underscore
underscore all?
Is this one underscore? One underscore. Okay. Got
it. One underscore all underscore.
Underscore.
Yep.
So you should oh, okay. I'm surprised, but
yeah.
But the idea is that it should be
able to give you all those. Anyways, we'll
we'll come back to that later. We'll look
at the schema right now. Yep.
So so the schema is basically
where your data lives.
So if you click bulk edit,
do you see bulk edit? Yep. Yep. Cool.
So this is this is
there you go.
So
line seven to line 10 is how a
type definition looks like.
Now this type definition is,
line seven to line 10 is by default
in all dgraph instances.
It allows dgraph to manipulate,
GraphQL natively.
So
I will talk about native GraphQL in a
bit, but, let's talk about types first, shall
we? So let's create a type called person
and create a type called book.
Okay. Just follow the syntax above.
Person.
And then
I have a name,
so it's going to be a string index.
Oh, no. No. That that's that's sorry. That's
the you you're using the GraphQL syntax. For
sorry. My bad. So this is this is
just straight up GraphQL then. Right? Here. Yeah.
That's that's straight up GraphQL.
So we're not gonna do that.
Let's see. Just just just type.
Yeah.
Well, that's that's a person type, and then
we wanted to
book,
which has a name.
No. No. You I'm sorry. My bad.
Yeah.
So so move name out of the out
of the type.
Of the book type?
So so move name out of that that
I let me type it for you.
Yeah. Let why don't we move this over
to Versus Code,
and then I can always paste oh, you're
doing it. Okay. Yeah.
So
so it looks like this. Right?
Okay.
So you've already got name, so you don't
have to write all those.
Okay. Okay. So I
understand.
So basically what we're saying is
these are the graph q l
definitions of types. A person has a name
property, has an age property, the book has
a name, and then
we specify something in Dgraphy syntax, which just
tells the the type semantics and the index
semantics for each of those properties. Exactly.
Okay. Exactly. My my my immediate question then
is what if I have a common property
across multiple types that need to be indexed
differently?
Ah, so you need to actually give it
a separate namespace.
So so I will walk you through that
in the GraphQL example. Okay. Okay. So so
if you use GraphQL,
all you're working in right now is DQL.
Right? So you're working in the lower level
stuff.
We we've sort of moved away from that.
We we we've started telling people that,
you should start with GraphQL, and and when
you need more power, move to DQL.
I personally find that a bit disorienting because
I start with DQL and then move to
GraphQL. Right? So,
yeah,
so so you just basically create a new
predicates on in France called person dot name,
for example.
Uh-huh. Index it one way, and then book
dot name, you index it another way.
So
does that mean that I can just do
book dot name like this? Yep.
And then say it's also a string, but
I wanna do a different index semantics and
say I do Hash. Hash. Yeah. Yep.
Can I just hit apply on the schema?
No. You have to actually change your book
line 19.
I thought does it become book dot name?
Yep.
Yep. Apply schema.
Sorry. Can we go back to bulk edit?
Oh, I wanna add the the edges.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. So so so
how
did book fly out there?
Was it Yeah. Think it's ordered it. Right?
This is alphabetical order of the types. We
can Yeah. Okay. Fair.
So so
under under type,
under person. Sorry. Yep.
Go down and then put reads.
No. No. As in just above just above.
Just just, yeah, under h and put livestream.
No. No. You don't have to open that.
Ah,
okay.
Livestreams.
Yep. So livestreams
already exist
if you look up there. Yeah.
So just change reads to the same as
live streams as a as a co as
a list of UIDs.
Yep.
Uh-huh.
Right. So so, basically, that's it. You've basically
created,
a definition of what a person is, and
note that you created the nodes before you
created the schema.
So if you click apply schema
Schema.
Yeah. Okay. Fair.
So you'll you'll need to you'll need to
yep. That's that's understandable.
So just let's just say read you you
only read one book.
Okay. So like that?
Yep.
Or no?
Yeah. Yeah. That works.
It it it still starts in the same.
Schema change not allowed from scaler to your
ID or base version, but there's data for
the Okay. Just click cancel then.
So we're gonna do a very dirty trick
that you probably shouldn't do in in real
life. So click, book. Click reads. Sorry.
Reads in the predicates. Yep.
Change it in here. So type change it
to straight,
UID.
List. Click list. Yep.
Sorry. Sorry. You might wanna drop data first.
You've got data as is, so just click
drop.
Yep.
Okay.
Sure.
Right.
Oh, dear.
And just do that thing that you just
did,
like reads. Yep.
And this is just because
I've been kind of making you make this
up as we go along and building the
schema that we have not really thought about.
Right? So this is Yeah. We really should
have talked about what we were gonna model
first. So yeah. Oopsie.
No problem looks like. We've got a Okay.
So just to understand what happened there is
that we were modifying our person.
We wanted to associate the live streams and
the books that we read
here. And then when we were trying to
add the index, I was just bailing because
we arbitrarily throw in on some random data
and it We just throwing the literal native
stream. Right? So it's not like an not
not a node. It's just literally a string.
Exactly. Right. Okay. That that makes sense to
me. I understand that the the I understand
the problem there. So we've now got a
schema where we're defined. So we're kind of
cherry picking some of the fields that exist
in the DQL format. We're starting to encapsulate
them in a type called a person in
a book and we've now added a few
indices that allow us to connect the dots
on that. That's kinda where I think we
are. Right? Okay. Yep.
Now I'm assuming we were doing that so
that when we come back to the reads
here
Yeah. You you need to go back to
the mutate section too. Oh, We don't have
any books anymore, do we? Yeah. Yeah. So
so back up here, you just go align
above it.
Mhmm.
Sorry. Align above. Yep. So underscore
press enter and underscore
node one.
Underscore colon node one.
You're missing a colon. Yep. Yep. Yep. Okay.
That syntax again. Okay. Yep. And book dot
name?
Yep.
You might wanna angle angle bracket angle angle
bracket. So
Yep.
Get it. Alright. So now we're creating our
books. Right? So I can see book dot,
and I can add in the three body
problem again.
Yep.
And so that's gonna create two book dot
name
You need the different node ID. Node one,
node two. Of course. Yeah.
And I'm assuming we can't do this yet
until we You can. That's that's what I'm
I want to tell you is that you
can. So it just goes instead replace that
empty empty thing with node one.
Ah.
Okay. So we're using the intermediate ID and
the set syntax, and that's just gonna be
propagated down to these. Mhmm. Right. Okay.
Can I have go on this? Yeah. Yeah.
You can run.
Oh, I'm sorry. You need angle brackets, I
believe. Oh, on the on the node one
and node two. Okay.
Node one and service
center.
Let me recall. I have I don't quite
remember this.
Sorry.
My bad.
Look. Listen. I
usually remember these are things. I work on
these.
I don't remember even what I had for
breakfast, so I'm I'm very comfortable looking things
up every time.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. So instead of this,
you need to put underscore
code underscore colon node one. There you go.
And remove the angle bracket. No. No. Remove
the angle brackets. Yeah. Because I'll okay. Right.
There you go. And you can have node
one that comes you can you can define
node one and node two after after after
that. It'll still work.
It's just that practice too.
Cool. That yeah. That makes that makes sense.
So now
I'm gonna just make stuff up again. So
I'm gonna say the book that'll be booked
on them. Right? So Yep. We don't use
the canonical in here.
Livestreams
hasn't changed.
Ah,
look at that. There you go.
And to make it to make it like
a proper graph, so you can add,
you can add
oh, I want to show you this as
well. So go back to mutate.
Yep.
This is very important to know. Right? So
keep the first two lines and change the
change the third line to o x two.
So that's me reading,
Dune.
Mhmm.
And close,
yeah. And if you run and if you
run the previous, run the query again,
and under livestream
We have to remove this. Right? No. No.
No. You don't have to. Just under livestream,
just put reads.
Yep. And then UID and book that name.
UID is not necessary. Right? So you'll note
that I'm
connected to a different
different dune
u 85.
Sorry. It should be booked up name, not
not name. Oh, yeah. Line 14. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. So so you run.
I'm connected to a different Dune,
and you're connected to two different three body
problems.
So if I understand
that correctly, that's because
this is also new in there every time?
Correct. Correct. So
this is something important to note.
It it run you you will run file
of it if you don't pay attention. So
Okay.
Let me I I guess I've got two
questions then. It's that
when we're using the mutate syntax to add
new reads
Yep. Can I also do a query to
fetch the books that I'm looking for? And
also, is it possible to add some sort
of unique constraints so that I don't end
up with two books with the same name?
Yeah. So those things are you you can
do all those things, but you generally need
some external help.
Okay.
So so you, like, you you you
would not be doing this in Rattle. You
would be doing this in via programming language.
Yeah. I guess this is a very contrived
situation right now just to kind of explore
the tools. This is not a workflow that,
by any means, we would suggest people do
and Yeah. To manipulate their data, of course.
So so I I personally use Rattle because
of its crazy
awesome
graph. Like, I can visualize, and that's crazy.
Right?
So this is a graph database in in
in its in its
core
is that you work on a graph.
Right? Okay. Yep. Yep. Yep. And and and
the thing about this is all nodes share
the same ID route, like UIDs. So if
you look at if you look at all
your UIDs for each of the node, they're
they're in increasing order. So you've got David
as UID, o x one,
me as u I u o I o
x two and all that, so on and
so forth. Yeah.
So this is a graph database
in a nutshell.
Now
with with graph with Dgraph, because it's it's
it's
distributed from from out of box,
it can get quite intimidating to to actually
run it on your own. Mhmm. The the
standalone docker image is fantastic
for
for experimenting,
prototyping.
You know? But,
you kinda need to read carefully
the, deploy section of the docs
on on on
we've got certain recommendations. So you need to
have, like, three nodes of alphas
at least in the production system. You need
to have 32 gigabytes of RAM minimum.
It's quite resource heavy.
So 32 gig of RAM. Wow. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. We we we've got people running out
of memory because graphs get very huge very
quickly. And,
one of the things that
that is beneficial in in a in a
SQL database is
compaction. Right? Because it's table, you can very
easily compact it. Whereas graphs are not so
easy to compact.
From from a graph have to store the
indices in memory at all time, or does
it fall back to disk?
So it it falls back to disk. Behind
the scenes, we use something called Badger.
It's a key value store to store all
the self
information.
And we've got also Ristretto, which is a
caching system,
which is
pretty awesome.
If you're into if you're into systems programming,
it's pretty awesome.
But what I'm trying to say is that
it and this is not a sales pitch.
Sorry. It's it's gonna sound like a sales
pitch, but it's not. Because I use slash
myself. Right?
Slash is the hosted version.
Alright. Okay.
This is the thing you asked me to
open up earlier. Right? Yeah. Slash is the
hosted version, and and
the direction the business has gone is to
to tell you that, hey. Guess what?
GraphQL is a first class citizen in a
graph database.
So think of slash GraphQL as as a
as a,
I don't know, RDS Amazon RDS, for example.
But yeah. Like, you you you don't need
to sell me on the merits of a
of a SaaS based database product because, I
mean, I used to work for a database
company and and flux data who are Yeah.
Founders
and maintainers of influx dp. Like, running stateful
workloads and production, especially if you if you
don't have experience of what's going on underneath
the hood. Like, I totally get it. It's
really difficult. And I would encourage people to
use these test product as often as possible.
So I I'm convinced like if if slash
graph q l is just gonna make my
database stateful site easier, then I'm all good.
I'm hoping what you're gonna tell me though,
there's a very generous free tier that I
can check the table. Very generous. You've got
10,000 credits, and 10,000 credits is
is is a lot. Right? So I managed
to port over
port over a a a a Postgres database,
and I have, like, what,
9,000 credits remaining.
So this
is rate limited to one request a second
after.
Oh, so I could still use it after
those 10,000 credits. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm just
I'm pretty sure my production applications are okay
with one request a second. I mean, I
can't surf at any traffic this other than,
well, me. So that's fine.
But what is the 10,000 queries mean? So
so
you saw those you saw those notes that
you just queried earlier in Rattle?
Yes.
Every GraphQL
query can be translated to a query that
touches notes.
Okay. So for
yeah. I'm not quite sure what the exact
numbers are, but I think for the first
hundred nodes that you touch is one credit.
And for the for the one
hundred and first to the first thousand nodes
is the second credit or something like that.
I leave those things to the bean counters.
I'm
Okay. So You know, I've I've got a
degree in mathematics just to to avoid doing
these tough things.
So anyway, click launch new back end.
Next to slash GraphQL. Yep. Yeah. I was
trying to work out why all of this
was grayed out, but I guess I need
to tell it to do something. So Yep.
Okay. So let's call this livestream.
It's optional.
I think Frankfurt's closest to you.
Yep. Let's go with Frankfurt.
A free plan.
Launch.
So this is spinning up
my own
Dgraph instance on AWS for me. This is
not like a shared multi tenancy global
platform provided by It's your own. Main.
Yes. Okay.
And, I think if you if you put
it nicely, they'll they'll actually connect you to
anyway,
the back ends.
I think you need to refresh the page.
It should be spun up by now.
And I think this is where oh, no.
Okay. This is where GraphQL,
Dgraph
actually really, really shines. Right? Once it's spun
up, just click schema. Okay. Click schema.
Right.
There's no schema right now,
but the best part is you can write
your own GraphQL schema.
Okay.
So so previously, you were writing,
DQL schemas. Right? You you're writing.
Right now, let's just write GraphQL schemas.
Okay. If you want, we can do the
same book example.
So we start with type person.
Do we is there a schema that's in
the docs that's recommended to use or get
a starter guide around for that rather than?
Yeah. Sure. Just go to GraphQL,
I guess.
Click on GraphQL. Click quick start.
Oh, well, d graph sorry. Sorry. Go go
back to slash. It's very interesting. Right? If
you go back to slash,
click
one click apps
on left.
So
Ah.
I'm immediately drawn to the Pokedex, but Click
on the Pokedex then. Yeah. Have a look
at the schema.
So deploy it.
Oh, it's okay. So I'm gonna get a
new
Yeah. Yeah.
Let's do that.
Get my own Pokedex. So
I I probably should have actually have clicked
the view code, but just what this spins
up. So these these one click apps are
like
schemas that are defined up front with some
data. I'm assuming that I can just immediately
query, modify,
etcetera, etcetera. I'm not sure about data. I
think the schemas are there. Schema will be
there. So I'm gonna have to create my
own Pokemon, but I I Yeah. So you
can just write your own mutations and write
create own Pokemon
Okay. Which is which is what every kid
has done.
Right. So I go to schema.
So oh, right. So you've got wow. Okay.
So we've got an enum so I can
specify the type of the Pokemon,
and then I can give it a name
or images
and whether it's been captured.
Yeah. That makes that's like a Pokedex.
Yeah. It's a Pokedex.
I just clicked on stuff now for the
for the the sake of clicking on it.
I'll stop. So
let's I'm assuming you're just gonna tell me
to go to API explorer.
Yeah. Just just click on the API explorer
and just write a query. You can you
can I personally use the API explorer quite
a lot? Oh. Data's there. Data. Yeah.
And image URL.
Oh, one credit.
Yeah. So it touches all these things. So
so
dgraph supports two language. I I I two
languages I told you from the start. Right?
DQ, and now you're seeing the,
the killer feature, I I I would say,
is that
imagine you just write an an a schema,
write the the GraphQL query,
and then you go a front end that
comes in and just points to slash GraphQL.
Yep.
That's
that is power.
You will eventually need to start using DQL
because there are things that GraphQL cannot do
just yet.
And I think I well, let's see if
my naive understanding of that is correct then.
Like, even though GraphQL is called graph QL.
I mean, it was traditionally run against relational
data structures or even JSON or document based
infrastructure. It was never initially actually used against
the graph DB to the best of my
knowledge. This is why people always talk about
the n plus one problem with GraphQL lookups
is that when
The over fetching bits. Yeah. When you when
you do like subtype
and then that has subtypes and then that
could have subtypes. So it's like generally that
query is then doing a lookup here, a
subsequent lookup here to the database and then
a subsequent lookup here. Does that problem go
away with Dgraph? Yes. Because, you know, your
your underlying structure is a graph. Yeah.
Unless you do something funny, which is like
a take a table
structure and try to structure it as a
graph and
and funny things happen.
Okay. So I I understand why the DQL
extensions need to exist because because GraphQL wasn't
built on graph databases. There's a lot of
that feature and functionality that just doesn't understand.
As as the graphical spec being modified to
accommodate some of these extensions or do you
always see the the a DQL just being
something that is required at a certain stage
of your adoption?
So I think over time, you're gonna need
custom resolvers for any any
large enough system. You're gonna need custom resolvers
for your
for your GraphQL.
Okay.
And
that's where you end up having to learn,
write DQL, I guess.
Okay. I guess that that yes. That that
makes sense to me. So
we've got our slash
GraphQL.
How do oh, I can just click and
run DQL query?
Yep. You
you will get pulled onto Rattle.
And yes. Oh, hang on. You're on play.dgraph.io.
Okay. So if you go back to your
own Rattle
My own. Yep. Yep. Go back to your
own Rattle and click on local host a
t a t on the top left.
You can choose to say connect to to
to your slash GraphQL.
I
don't remember the Yeah. I'm gonna find the
Go go go to the other Rattle. Go
to the play Rattle, the the the site
the the new Rattle.
Not I don't think that's the correct one.
You go to the tab next to it,
and then click on
that, and it actually
Alright. So that is the URL I copied,
but there was
API key. Yeah. That's
oh, there we go.
So now you are connected to your slash
DraftQO instance from Rattle.
I don't believe it yet. Hold on.
Let
me copy
where is it? Oh, sorry.
Caveat.
Rattle is only DQL.
There are plans to
there are plans for you to actually write
GraphQL in Rattle soon,
but
the dev team's a bit swamped right now.
Oh, yeah. Okay. So,
like,
does Rattle provide the same like, I'm I'm
not sure what tools that's this looks like
one of the, you know, various GraphQL explosions.
Yeah. You can use GraphQL to connect to
this. Yeah. Does Rattle provide some sort of
query exposition
thing or browser like we have here? You
know, I I I can see the filter.
I can see the schema. Can I do
that with Rattle?
You can see the schema by clicking on
schema, for example.
Click refresh scheme. I don't think it like
my random setup, so I'll just use this
one.
Yep.
Schema.
Okay.
See? All all the Pokemon, like, schemas have
been nicely namespaced for you.
Okay. So I think the problem with my
rattle then is that I just
didn't have auto complete because it wasn't actually
connected. So this Right. This this is actually
working there.
Yeah.
Cool. Oh, no.
Sorry. Sorry. You're Yeah. You're in a schema
query.
You need to give a function name.
Oh, yeah. Alright. Okay. Like like traditional.
Pokemon.
So
that was something like
this,
and then we also had to do
funk Funk. Has
type? You don't have okay. So you you
I can you can type
instead of has type, you can just do
type bracket poke type bracket Pokemon.
Alright. Okay. Type
Pokemon. Pokemon.
Right? And you should run. Woah. There you
go.
Okay. Cool.
So we do get quite a fair bit
of data then. Yep.
Let's see. Pokemon. That's not look like a
51.
Yeah. I'm not sure. I don't know if
any of them are captured. So can I
change this type? Like, what if I want
only wanna put a captured true?
So
you can so in in DQL, you can
you can do something called filters.
Mhmm.
So
type Pokemon and then space filter.
No. No. I sent the line two. Sorry.
Oh, okay.
And then after the after the close-up bracket
Here?
Yep.
Add filter alias filter.
Alias filter?
The at symbol. Sorry. Yeah. The at the
at symbol. At at filter. Yeah. And then
open bracket.
Yep.
And then you can type things like,
e q. You need e q. You need
a function in there. So e q,
pokemon.
Captured it true.
Yep.
Oh, I haven't captured any Pokemon.
Yeah.
So if you click on the JSON and
request,
on the right, so JSON,
it'll actually tell you, okay. It there was
no, like, hidden errors or anything. So, yeah,
that you did not capture any Pokemon.
Okay.
Well well, I guess that gives me something
I have to do at some point. So
the DQL syntax then is we can just
do filters. We can use any of the
functions that are available. Did it offer to
yeah. No. It doesn't auto complete the functions.
So you just It does. It does? It
should auto it should auto complete, at least
my my mind does.
Yeah.
Maybe it's just me. I'm not sure.
How do I get a list then? At
least in the is there a list of
functions I can get from the documentation?
So, yeah, it's a yeah. Go to documentation.
Go to DQL.
Go query language. Yeah. Functions.
Ta da. See, I I love it when
I can just go to the talks and
kinda quickly find what I'm looking for. Okay.
So we can link this all of the
terms. There's the filters,
regular expressions. Alright. Okay. So
there's
There are a lot of crazy things that
you can do, like aggregation,
which you can't do in deep in GraphQL.
There's also
full text search language specific.
Ah, yes.
Yes. Yes.
So so so if you put an alias,
and then a language code after a string
field
So a string field can have multiple languages.
I'm trying to see. Does it have an
example of
this? So yeah. Yeah. It should.
You can go to Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So we do all of. Let me zoom
in on that a little bit.
Yeah. If we do
all of match and then name and then
at e n, so we can specify the
language and that changes the semantics of the
match, the equals, etcetera. Yep. Yep. That's very
cool.
So that's that's one of the extensions that
that DQL has that GraphQL can't do,
I guess.
Yeah. That that definitely would not be possible
using
GraphQL
things at all.
But it's it's nice that that is there.
Does that change the way that my strings,
like, the index side, they have to specify
the the language? Or Yeah. You do. If
you go go to the original rattle, your
local host rattle you can go to rattle
and any rattle.
Go to schemas.
Yeah. Go to this one because it's currently
working.
Yeah. Click on, click on the name, for
example,
and you can click on check on lang.
So it it will now index based on
how many languages it is. So if it's
in there there is no language, then it's
treated as a, I believe, English, I think.
Okay.
Yeah. I'm not sure. Okay. Cool.
I like that. That's a very interesting thing
that I hadn't really considered.
Awesome.
Yeah. Dgraph
also supports things like geo,
like I did notice that on our
was it on the console? Yeah. There was
this geo thing here. I
I'm assuming that just means that
latitude, longitude, types of Correct. Properties are just
naturally supported, natively supported? Natively
supported. Yes.
So this is saying that I'll read this.
Objects must contain a predicate or alias location.
Okay. So as long as I have something
called location that looks like a lot long,
it's gonna map that for me on this?
Correct.
Does that I I'm assuming that I can
also query that and say, show me all
of the
the nodes that have some property within a
certain radius of this location. Like, I wanted
to find all of the bars or restaurants
near my city,
this natively works. Right? Yep. Natively works.
Cool.
Awesome. Joe is pretty awesome.
I've not actually had I've not actually personally
had the the opportunity to play around with
Joe, so I can't tell you much about
it, but I know it works.
Yeah. So I guess, I mean,
I'm not gonna make you do it now
because of of timing constraints here, but definitely
something I wouldn't be playing with in the
future. But if I wanted to store
if my capture of a Pokemon was an
actual type,
could store the latitude and longitude. Like I'm
thinking of a Pokemon Go, if I'm walking
down the street and I Yeah. Capture Pokemon,
I could store that lat and long and
then I could actually probably pull out what
I caught within local vicinity.
That is correct.
Awesome.
I think this is a really, really cool
tool and
I definitely
understand the applications of a graph database for
certain data models and how that is gonna
give me a lot of benefits to the
way that I work in slice and dice
the data and all of that.
Very exciting tool. Maybe
we could talk about sorry, before
we move on, is there anything from the
rattle side or the documentation or the slash
side that you want to cover before I
can
move away? I guess I no. I'm I'm
good.
Alright. I I there there are a lot
more in documentation.
Like, you can do multiple query blocks, but
you can do that in DraftQ as well.
Yeah. I I the way I see it
is if you want to launch your apps
fast
and your data model is sane,
use slash.
Right? Okay. Sorry. That sounded very salesy. I'm
not I'm not supposed to sell you anything.
Yeah. So
but that's what I've been doing. Right? So
I've got some personal projects that I run,
and I just use slash. And strangely, it's
free. So
you know? Yeah. I I mean, I think
this has been a really cool introduction to
to Dgraph and hopefully just the general concept
of of GraphQL to the people that's new
to it and then graph databases beyond that.
I think I do have real world applications
for this that I think it would be
really cool if I could start to build
those out for our, you know, our team
at Equinix Meta, we have our own tooling,
our own platforms. And I think a graph
DB would be really cool here. So maybe,
you know
you know, sometime next year once we have
that working, maybe it would be cool to
have you back on and do a bit
of a deeper dive into some of the
things that we're doing and optimize Absolutely. But
I think it's an introduction. This was was
fantastic. So I'll down a share and we'll
just, know,
what's
you know, what's
is Dgraph a fast moving project? What's coming
next? What's what's changing? What are the team
working on? Like, what what is the focus
right now for for Dgraph?
So the the the main focus is to
make GraphQL
work even better. There are a lot of
a lot of extensions, cascades, and stuffing that
are coming
in the next version.
Supporting, for example, one of my biggest requests
personal requests is supporting
XIDs.
So so in in Dgraph terms, XIDs are
external IDs.
So you've got you've got Postgres database with
a int,
and you can just annotate yours your your
your your GraphQL
schema with at ID, and then it will
sort of in implement all the constraints of
when ID is.
Right now, the ID the at ID only
works for strings, but I think in the
future, integer types are coming.
So so that that basically allows people to
move from one database to another database quite
easily.
There's a lot of work done. Most of
the work has been done most on on
on on GraphQL and improving
the things that you can do with GraphQL.
If you if you go back to slash,
you you'll see that, like, Dgraph basically generates
all the GraphQL functions for you.
So so the the query, my Pokemon, for
example,
is generated by Dgraph.
When you put when when you create a
a GraphQL schema, it creates this function for
you.
Uh-huh. Okay. Yeah.
And and
more more
being created. So so on later versions of
of,
dgraph, it also generates, for example, get Pokemon.
It's self query Pokemon. It's get Pokemon where
you can get just by an ID.
And then if you if you look at
the bottom
Oh, where's the here?
Yeah. At the bottom, it shows mutation. You
click at choose mutation and add.
Click on the plus.
So you can you all all these add,
delete, and update, they're all automatically generated by
Dgraph.
Ah, so I can actually see captured
let me
run that first. Okay. So I'm gonna
I'm gonna capture a Pokemon.
You you want you want the EU IT?
I was gonna add a new Pokemon and
just mark it as captured. So now I'm
I think I think what I'm doing is
adding
Pokemon
called Rawkode,
which is now being captured and I'll add
the image URL
Pokemon. I'll be a bug Pokemon. I don't
mind being a bug Pokemon.
At least like that ID was actually maybe
required.
Yeah. It is.
So I'll just be 32,000.
I'll assume that's available. Too big. It is
it is acceptable. Yeah.
It the the reason why you're having that
is because you need to
yeah. It's no. UID is ID. Actually, it's
it's ID.
There we go. Yeah.
I think this will fail because you forgot
to put square brackets outside of the input,
outside of the the object.
So add Pokemon takes an input of a
list.
Okay. Right now, you've got a list of
up you've you've got a single object. Yeah.
There you go. And and you should delete
the top query Pokemon bit bit.
Yep.
So
And now you need to you need to
tell,
you need to tell the GraphQL thing what
you want out. So add Pokemon
bracket. So
Like that? Now you can type num UIDs.
Sorry. I didn't understand that. I can type
num UIDs,
n u m. Okay. K. Yep. There you
go. So that tells you how many was
added. If you run that, that should tell
you one was added.
Oh, so I think this was supposed to
be a left
based on yeah. There we go. Yep. Alright.
Let's
I'm gonna delete this. I'm going back to
my query and and
oh, no. I needed it from here because
I want the geo no, not geo. I
want a captured query which I already did.
So I'm just gonna hit run.
And recognize
I I changed the the filter. We never
actually run.
We did one that filter, didn't we?
Pokemon captured true.
The the k. Go scroll down to your
history, I guess.
One of the filters work. The first first
filter. Yeah.
Click on it, and you should click run.
Scroll up. Click on it and click run.
No. No. Don't yeah.
There
you go. I'm
making things difficult for myself. Okay. There's a
way that that's nice. I I like this
this slash interface with, you know, the clicky
bits. It makes it just a lot a
little bit easier. And I actually really enjoyed
that. But if we were to rebuild that
query, right, if I were just to say
show me
captured, I can even just do the filter
through this. Yeah. You can do the filter
on on
So I can just say, get me captured
Pokemon. I want their ID, the image, their
name, and their types.
So go
Oh, you want to filter with captured false.
So
Oh, I could have changed it to here
too. Oh, I updated it there too as
well. Okay.
There we go. There you go.
And it cost me another credit, but you
know, I've got I've got plenty left. It's
not a big deal. Yeah. Yeah. So I
think that that's last tooling is really nice
and intuitive and just simplifies like, know, a
lot of people have your especially if you're
new to GraphQL and you wanna start experimenting
this workflow.
Is really nice. And I think it'll just
ease people into how they work and construct
their own GraphQL queries over time. Yeah. Very
cool.
Awesome.
Well, let me pop that away.
That's been a really cool look at Dgraph.
I can see a lot of power, lot
of flexibility. I love the fact that I,
you know, even as we were making stuff
up at the start about what our queries
were and what our schema was, it really
did give me the flexibility to go in
and add those indices retrospect, which I love.
Yeah. The the ability for me to manipulate
and change that schema. I think it's really
cool as well. Great.
I'm gonna have to keep playing with us.
I will definitely get something worked out for
next year where we can do this deeper
dive into DQL and more real world applications.
But I think it's an introduction. This is
fantastic. I just wanna say thank you for
staying up so late. No problems.
Now can I can I can I ask
for something? Sorry. Yeah. Of course. So so
there's a website called discuss.dgraph.io,
which is where the community lives. Most of
the questions are there.
If you if you if
you come to discuss.dgraph.io,
you ask a question, you're probably gonna get
an answer within
twenty four hours or so. It's quite active.
So
yeah.
You know you've got a problem, just pop
right in there. We're also running a conference,
like Go system conference, if you do Go
programming.
You know?
Go what's it called? I I don't know
the URL. Sorry. Systems.
So it's it's on the it's on the
front page of of the discuss.
There you go.
Oh, it's right there in front of my
face. Right. Yeah. Yeah.
There you go. So we can click on
yeah. Oh, that's an image. That's that's the
link. Yeah.
But, again, this this is really spooky stuff.
You know?
Yeah. It's online.
There are some really, really
cool speakers that we've landed. Yeah.
If you're into systems programming at all, check
it out.
Awesome. Okay. So, yeah, if you've got Dgraph
questions and you want some help, go to
the discourse forum at discuss.dgraph.io
and systemsconf.io
if you're interested in going systems programming.
Awesome. I'll get registered for that after this
episode.
That's the thing with like with all these
virtual conferences this year, there's been so many
of them. It's been fantastic that I could
just sit and watch so many conference talks
online.
Really,
it has downside as well and that there's
no too many technologies that I wanna go
play with.
Yeah. Know.
That's a good problem to have I think.
Alright. Thank you for that. And and thanks
again for staying up late. I know
It was a pleasure doing this. It was
fun. Quite fun. Yeah. Awesome. Then I look
forward to having you back. Have a a
great evening and I'll speak to you soon.
Have a good day. Thanks. Bye.